foreign
[Music]
PayPal is by far one of the most
functional apps in the world we use it
to pay rent private teachers contractors
Freelancers friends family and even
certain purchases PayPal made sending
and receiving money through the internet
more straightforward than ever before
all you needed was someone's email
address you didn't need to deal with the
bank accounts or routing numbers or any
of that just make sure you typed in
their email correctly and hit send
ironically this is not what PayPal was
actually created for the founders
envisioned that PayPal would be an
internet-based financial management
system and sending money using email
addresses was just a side feature yet it
quickly became the main feature we can't
forget about venmo either who PayPal
acquired back in 2013. in the US venmo
is so popular for splitting bills that
has become a verb like Google
considering the popularity and the
functionality of PayPal I don't think
you'd be rised here that PayPal boasts a
market cap of 100 billion dollars and
that's with the 75 sell-off but what is
surprising though is that people aren't
exactly fans of PayPal in fact PayPal
has quite a negative reputation several
months ago I posted a video about the
downfall of PayPal stock and most of
their comments were actually happy that
PayPal was getting destroyed PayPal is
an old attack and it's total garbage I
hope this company goes a bankrupt good I
hate that company PayPal is a terrible
company that I only deal with when I
have to glad there are other options now
it's not just my YouTube comments that
were so critical of PayPal either after
a little digging I quickly realized that
people don't just have problems with
PayPal they actually utterly despise the
company take trustpilot for example
PayPal has a solid 23 000 reviews on
trustpilot but 87 of those reviews are
literally one star and only a mere eight
percent or five star so how did such a
useful and seemingly neutral company
earn such a terrible reputation
foreign
use cases of PayPal is to pay
third-party sellers that you don't fully
trust if the seller does try to pull a
quick one you would hope that PayPal
would side with the customer and help
facilitate a refund but according to the
vast majority of online anecdotes PayPal
never sides with the customer even when
there are several red flags it and a
bunch of evidence take red hat 27's
experience for example Red Hat tried to
buy one of these wide security cameras
from a third-party seller using PayPal
but as you would guess red hat would
never receive his camera so he would
file a clan with paypala and do some
digging on his own first he tried
calling the seller's phone number and
the person that picked up was some tow
truck driver apparently the tow truck
driver was receiving over 300 calls
every day from people who had fallen for
this scam and he had already reported it
to the police and the Better Business
Bureau you would think that this
information alone was enough for PayPal
to side with red hat but red hat had
even more evidence
he went ahead and called ups and UPS
would confirm that the parcel wasn't
even being shipped to his home address
what this camera did do though was ship
some sort of parcel to the same city and
state this way when you track the
package online where only the city and
state are displayed it looks like the
package was delivered correctly PayPal
would take this as evidence that the
package was indeed delivered and closed
the case against the red hat all PayPal
had to do was call UPS about the
shipment and it would have been clear
who was on the right side but PayPal
couldn't even do that while the vast
majority of complaints surrounding
PayPal are by related it would be unfair
to say that it's only the buyers that
are getting scammed the vast majority of
PayPal customers are buyers and that's
why their stories dominate the internet
but there's plenty of seller horror
stories as well one of these stories
comes from a man named Andy Dollinger
who sells electronics online one day
Andy received an inquiry from a customer
regarding abuse blindership products to
India Andy had no problem shipping
products internationally but he was a
bit concerned about the buyer's account
apparently the account was created
within the last month and only had to
pause the feedbacks nonetheless Andy
decided to give the buyer the benefit of
the doubt and shipped him a 1500 iPhone
12 Pro Max it took some time for the
product to reach the scammer but as soon
as he received it he filed a complaint
that the Box didn't contain the phone
Andy would reach out to DHL who
graciously provided CCTV footage that
proved the weight of the box and he also
contacted his supplier Who provided
evidence that the box with the phone
weighed the same amount and Andy turned
over both pieces of evidence to PayPal
at first it seemed like PayPal actually
sided with Andy but two weeks later Andy
received an email letting him know that
they had decided to side with the buyer
since then and he has called the Indian
police the European consumer Center and
sent over more evidence to PayPal but
none of this has gotten Andy his money
back as you can see PayPal doesn't
necessarily always aside with the buyer
or the seller per se but it does seem
like they usually side with this camera
the reason for this is that the scammers
are keenly aware of exactly how PayPal
conducts their dispute investigations
and they precisely structure their
thoughts to fall through PayPal's gaps
for example the first scammer knew to
send the product to the same city and
state and the second scammer knew to use
a new account without a bad track
history you would think that PayPal
would be aware of these loopholes in
their system and maybe they are but
given the raw number of PayPal horror
stories online it doesn't seem like
they've made any quantifiable change
foreign
customer service you would think that
PayPal would at least charge lower fees
but this is not the case either
if you're a buyer or simply sending
money to friends and family you probably
haven't noticed this because PayPal is
free for you but the same cannot be said
about Merchants you see it whenever a
customer uses PayPal for checkout the
merchant has to Fork over 3.5 percent
plus a fixed fee straight to PayPal this
might be viable for large retailers like
Walmart and the target but for small
Merchants landlords and private teachers
this fee is substantial for example
let's say that you're trying to rent out
your parents old house for twelve
hundred dollars per month at three and a
half percent forty two dollars would go
straight to PayPal every single month
through the course of an ear that works
out to over 500 and that's just for
domestic transactions if you're engaging
with International customers and a deal
with some sort of currency exchange
you're gonna have to Fork over
conversion fee to PayPal as well by the
time International Merchants pay all the
fees they've often lost five percent of
the transaction value even credit cards
who are known for having high fees have
lower fees than that visa and the
MasterCard for example charge one and a
half to two and a half percent and even
American Express only charges two and a
half to three and a half percent not to
mention all of these networks provide
fraud protection and customer service
that are leagues above PayPal so with
PayPal Merchants are often forced to pay
higher fees for a worse service that
neither dammit nor their customers are
happy with want to work around it for
these fees is to just complete personal
transaction instead of merchant
transactions however this isn't not only
against the PayPal's terms of service
but most customers are hesitant to
choose this option especially when it
comes to online transactions with
unknown sellers so while most sellers
would love to ditch PayPal they can't
because PayPal is often the standard and
that's what many customers are used to
fortunately friendlier options like Zell
which charge no fees are starting to
grow in popularity but in the meantime
sellers can't do anything other than be
frustrated with PayPal
foreign
cite a wide variety of complaints when
it comes to PayPal whether it be
scammers High fees or frozen funds it
seems to me that the key reason for
almost all of PayPal's issues is that
they're not regulated like a traditional
Financial firm on one side they're kind
of a bank but they don't have to follow
the same rules as Wells Fargo or chase
on another side they're also kind of a
payment network but they don't offer the
same Consumer Protection Services as
American Express or VISA initially this
lack of regulatory oversight was thanks
to PayPal's unique business model they
were one of the first to jump into this
world of Internet Finance so Regulators
simply didn't know how to regulate them
PayPal fell into this gray area similar
to crypto brokerages today and I think
we all know how that turned out just
take a look at the Voyager or Celsius
PayPal hasn't been engaging in anything
anywhere near as risky as those two and
that's why they haven't completely
collapsed but this isn't to say that
PayPal services are making anyone
especially happy I mean there is a
reason that there are rules and
regulations running cash reserves fraud
protection and fees that traditional
Banks must follow throughout the past
100 years Regulators have figured out
that without these rules and regulations
in place it becomes increasingly likely
that consumers are taken advantage of
now this isn't to say that PayPal does
not follow any rules whatsoever as
Regulators better understand the
internet they have been getting stricter
when it comes to the activities of
Institutions like PayPal for example
PayPal has to abide by the following
government regulations payments
regulation banking agency supervision
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
anti-money laundering and interchange
fees while this is definitely a step in
the right direction PayPal still doesn't
deal with anywhere near as much
oversight as traditional financial
institutions and I'm sure that paper's
lawyers and the lobbyists are being paid
extremely well to make sure that that
doesn't change and honestly you can't
even blame them for that because any
business owner would want the same but
that doesn't mean that this Choice
doesn't have consequences for their
customers
in the end while regulation May fix some
of PayPal shortfalls regulation it is
rarely an ultimate solution for PayPal
to really turn things around and improve
their reputation in the business change
has to come from within one of the
easiest places that they can invest in
it is their customer support
seems that their dispute teams just want
to close cases as fast as possible while
following PayPal protocol when their
goal should be to uncover the truth and
side with the correct party I mean this
sounds like a no-brainer but given all
the stories online this is obviously not
what's taking place in terms of fees
while their fees are high I don't think
PayPal has to reduce their fees per se
usually it's not high fees alone that
for your customers what actually
triggers customers is paying high fees
for crappy Services there are so many
businesses that charge High fees and
offer a premium service and their
customers love them I mean one of these
companies is literally the largest
company in the world Apple so PayPal
could definitely played this card as
well but as long as there's a gaping
disparity between the cost of PayPal and
the perceived value of their services I
doubt that PayPal's reputation will
improve but that's just what I think do
you have a positive opinion on PayPal
comment that down below also drop a like
if you hope that PayPal turns things
around at least for the sake of their
customers and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community
suggest for the video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions of
logically answered until then I'm Hari
and I'll see you guys on the next one